Sentell
survey it this morning about how the
class is going where you thought of a
problem set and I would appreciate if
you provide us provide me some feedback
so things you like or don't like about
the class or about the problem said that
was just you last night so it's I can
try to adjust to make it more
interesting and useful for all of you
last time we talked about similarities
craft regularity lemma
so the regularity lemma as I mentioned
is a extremely powerful tool in modern
combinatorics and last time we saw the
statement and the proof of this
regularity lemma today I want to show
you how to apply the right dilemma for
extremal applications in particular
we'll see how to prove
Rost theorem that I mentioned in the
very first lecture about subsets of
integers lacking three term arithmetic
progressions
first I will you remind you the
regularity lemma we're always working
inside some graph G we say that a pair
of subsets of vertices is epsilon
regular if the following holds for all
subsets a of X P of Y neither too small
we have that intensity edge density
between a and B it's very similar to the
edge density between the ambient sets x
and y so we had this picture from last
time
you have two sets no they don't have to
be destroyed they could even be the same
set but for illustration purposes it's
easier to visualize what's going on if I
draw them as just disjoint subsets so
there's some edge density and I said
there Absalon regular if they behave
random like in the following sense
that the edges are somehow distributed
in a fairly uniform way so that if I
look at some smaller subsets a and B /
not not too small then the edge
densities between a and B is very
similar to the ambient edge densities so
by at most epsilon difference now I need
that a and B are not too small because
if you allow to take for example single
vertices you can easily get densities
that are either 0 or 1 so then it's very
hard to make any useful statements so
that's why these two conditions are
needed and here the edge density is
defined to be the number of edges with
one endpoint in a one endpoint in B
divided by the product of the sizes of a
and B and we say that a partition of the
vertex set of the graph is epsilon
regular if by summing over all pairs IJ
such that VI VJ is not epsilon regular
if we sum up the product of these part
sizes then this sum is at most an
epsilon fraction of the total number of
pairs of vertices well the way to think
of this is that there are not too many
irregular parts at least in the case
when all the parts are
so you should really think about all of
them having more or less the same size
than saying that a most an epsilon
fraction of them are irregular and the
main theorem from last time was cemre
ids regularity lemma and the statement
is that for every epsilon there exists
some mm M depends only on epsilon and
not on the graph that we're about to see
such that every graph has an epsilon
regular partition into at most M parts
in particular the number of parts does
not depend on the graph it's for every
epsilon there's some m and no matter how
large the graph there exist a bounded
size partition that is epsilon regular
so the proof last time gave us a bound M
that is quite large as a function of
Epsilon there's the last time we saw
that this M was a power of two's of
height essentially polynomial in 1 over
Epsilon and I mentioned that you
basically cannot improve this bound so
this bound is more or less best possible
up to maybe changing the 5 so in some
sense the proof that we gave last time
for similarities graph regularity lemma
was the right proof so that was the
sequence of steps they were the right
things to do even though they gave a
terrible bound it's somehow the thing
the bound that should come out okay what
I want to talk about today is what's a
regularity partition good form
so we did all this work to get a
regularity partition that has all of
these nice definitions but they are
useful for something I said what it it's
a useful form and here is the intuition
that remember the at the beginning of
last lecture I mentioned this informal
statement of regularity lemma namely
that there exists a partition of the
graph so that most pairs look random
like so what does random like me so
random like there's a specific
definition but the intuition is that in
many aspects especially when it comes to
counting small patterns the graph in a
random like setting looks it's very
similar to what happens in a random
graph in a genuine random graph and in
particular if you have three subsets x y
and z and suppose that the three pairs
are all epsilon regular then you might
be interested in the number of triangles
with one vertex in each set now if this
were a genuine random tripartite graph
with a specified edge densities then the
number of triangles in such a random
graph is pretty easy to calculate you
expect that elissa around the product of
the sizes of these vertex sets
multiplied by their edge densities and
what we will see is that in this case in
that of epsilon regular setting this is
also a true statements a true
deterministic statement and that's one
of the consequences of epsilon
regularity yes question
asking why are we only multiplying the
sizes of XY and Z so you're asking okay
so we're trying to find out how many
triangles are there with one vertex in X
one vertex in Y and one vertex in Z
right so if I put these vertices in
there one by one then if this were a
random graph I expect that pair to be an
edge with probability D X Y and so on so
if the all the edge densities were 1/2
then I expect 1/8 of these triples to be
actual triangles and what we're saying
is that in an epsilon regular setting
that is approximately a true statement
okay so let me formalize this intuition
into an actual statement and this type
of statements are known as counting
Lamas in literature and in particular
let's look at the triangle counting them
in a triangle counting lemma okay so
we're using the same picture over there
I have three vertex subsets some given
graph again they don't have to be
destroyed they could overlap but it's
fine to think about that picture over
there and suppose that these three pairs
of subsets so these three subsets they
are mutually Epsilon regular
then and for abbreviation let me write
the sub XY to be the edge density
between x and y and so on for the other
two pairs the conclusion is that the
number of triangles where I'm looking at
triangles and only counting triangles
with one specified vertex in X 1 in Y
and one in Z is at least some quantity
so there's a small potential error loss
but otherwise the product as I mentioned
earlier so it's at least this quantity I
mentioned earlier up to your potential
small error because no we're looking at
epsilon regularity so there could be
some fluctuations in both directions a
similar statement is also true as an
upper bound but the lower bound will be
more useful so I will show you the proof
of the lower bound but you you can
figure out how to do the upper bound and
later on we'll see a general proof what
happens instead of triangles if you have
other sub graphs that you wish to count
so here's the intuition you have a
random like setting and we'll formalize
it in the setting of epsilon regular
pairs okay the question is where does 1
minus epsilon come from you're seeing
the proof but you should think of this
as essentially a negligible factor any
more questions all right so here's how
this proof is going to go
let's look at X and think about its
relationship to Y its epsilon regular
and I claim as a result of them being
epsilon regular fewer than epsilon
fraction of X so fewer than this many
vertices in X have a very small number
of neighbors in Y because if this were
not the case then you can violate the
condition of epsilon regularity if not
then let's look at this subset which has
sighs at least epsilon X and all of them
have fewer than that number of neighbors
to Y so these two sets so this set X
Prime and Y with witness Nong epsilon
regularity so you cannot have too many
vertices with small degrees going to X
to go into y okay great and likewise
fewer than epsilon X vertices have a
small number of neighbors to Z
okay so what does a picture now look
like so you have this X and then these
two other sets y&z where I'm going to
throw out a small proportion of X less
than 2 epsilon fraction of X they have
the wrong kinds of degrees and
everything else in here have lots of
neighbors in both Y and in Z in
particular for all X up here it has a
lot of neighbors to Y lots of neighbors
to see how many we have at least P sub X
Y minus epsilon Y neighbors to Y and at
least P sub X Z minus epsilon times Z
neighbors to Z and ok
so now realize that missing a hypothesis
in the continent let me assume that none
of these edge densities are too small
they're all at least two Epsilon so now
these guys are at least epsilon
fractions of Y & Z so I can apply the
definition of epsilon regularity to the
pair Y Z to deduce that there are lots
of edges between these two sets so over
here the number of edges is at least the
product of these sizes multiplied by the
edge density between them and by the
definition of epsilon regularity the
edge density between these two smaller
these two red sets is at least D of Y Z
minus Epsilon so putting everything now
together we find that the total number
of triangles looking at all the possible
places where X can go these 1 minus 2
epsilon times the size of X and I
multiplied by this factor
over here so we find the statement up
there so this calculation formalizes the
intuition now if you have epsilon
regular pairs then they behave like
random settings when it comes to
counting small patterns namely that of a
triangle okay so what can we use this
for the next statement I want to show
you is called a triangle we move all
Emma okay so this is a somewhat
innocuous looking statement that she's
surprisingly tricky to proof and part of
the development of this regularity lemma
was to prove similar to triangle removal
Emma this is one in the early
applications of the regularity lemma
that's always do to Gousha and
similarity back in the 70s here's a
statement for every epsilon there exist
a delta such that every graph and
vertices with a small number of
triangles so small number of triangles
means a negligible fraction of all the
possible triples of vertices are actual
triangles so fewer than Delta and cubed
triangles okay so if you have a graph
with the small number of triangles
questions can you make a triangle free
by getting rid of a small number of
edges actually there was already a
problem on the first problem on the
first homework set that is in that
spirit but you see this okay so if you
compare what I'm doing here to the
homework
you see that there are different scales
so fewer than Delta and cube triangles
can be made triangle free by removing
epsilon and squared edges okay so if you
have a small number of triangles you can
get rid of all the triangles by removing
a small number of edges if I put it that
way actually sounds kind of trivial
right you just get rid of all the
triangles but if you look at the scales
it's not review at all because there are
only a sub cubic number of triangles so
if you take out one edge from each
triangle maybe you got rid of a lot of
edges so this is a very innocent looking
statement but it's actually incredibly
deep and tricky before jumping to the
proof let me first show you a equivalent
reformulation of the statement that also
helps you to think about we know what
this statement is trying to say so the
triangle removal emmab can be
equivalently stated as saying that every
end vertex graph with a sub cubic number
of triangles so little all of n cubed
triangles can be made triangle free
by removing a sub-quadratic namely
little o of N squared number of edges
okay so this is an equivalent statement
to what I wrote above although you
actually take some thought to figure out
what this is even saying because
everybody loves using asymptotic
notation but there's also ambiguity with
what do you mean by asymptotic notation
especially if it appears in the
hypothesis of a claim okay so so what do
you think this statement means can you
write out more of a full form so I think
of this as a lazy version of trying to
say something right so what do you mean
by having butovo of n cubed triangles
yes
okay great so I have sequence of graphs
and also you can put some functions in
alright so that's so I'll write down the
statement here but that's kind of the
idea were looking at not just a single
graph but we're looking at a sequence
another way to say this is that for
every function FN that is sub-q Bukh so
for example of f of n is n cube divided
by log n there exists some function G
which is sub-quadratic such that if you
replace the first one by f of N and the
second thing by G event and this is a
true statement and I leave it to you as
an exercise and quantify elimination
let's say to explain why these two
statements are equivalent to each other
all right I want to explain a recipe for
applying similarities regularity lemma
how does one use the regularity lemma to
proof for statements in graph theory the
most standard applications of regularity
lemma generally have the following steps
let me call this a recipe and we'll see
it a few times
the first step is what we apply
somewhere these regularity lemma to
obtain a partition so let me call the
first step partition in the second step
we look at the partition that we obtain
and we clean it up so in the partition
you have some irregular pairs that that
are undesirable to work with and there
are some other pairs that we'll see so
in particular if you our pair involves
edges that are fairly sparse or subsets
of vertices that are fairly small then
maybe we don't want to touch them
because they're kind of not so good to
deal with so we're going to clean the
graph by removing edges in irregular
pairs and low-density pairs
and unless you're using the version of
regularity lemma that allows you to have
equitable parts you also want to get rid
of edges where one of the parts there's
too small okay
and the third step coders count once
you've cleaned up the regularity
partition say well let's try to find
some patterns if you find one pattern in
the cleaned graph and we can use the
counting them up
to find lots of patterns here for the
purpose of triangle remover lemma and
what we've been doing so far pattern
just means a triangle so we're going to
use the triangle counting lemma to find
us lots of triangles so we'll see the
details in a bit but if we run through
this strategy you give me a graph let's
say it so starting from the triangle
removal Emma has a small number of
triangles you apply the partition clean
it up and I claim this cleaning removes
a small number of edges and it should
result in a triangle free graph because
if it did not result in a triangle free
graph then there's some triangle and
from that triangle I can apply the
triangle County lemma to get lots of
triangles and now would have violated
the hypothesis of the triangle removal
lemma so that's how the proof is going
to go okay so I want to take a very
quick break and then when we come back
well see the details of how to apply the
regularity lemma
are there any questions so far yep okay
so you're asking about what happens when
we remove vertex that are to vertex s
that are too small okay you are seen the
details of the proof so hold on to that
question for a bit more questions okay
so let's see the proof of the triangle
removal MO it so the first step is to
apply similarities regularity lemma and
find a partition so we'll find a
partition that's epsilon over four
regular okay so here epsilon is the same
epsilon in the statement in the top
statement of the triangle removal and in
the second step let's clean the graph by
removing all edges in so we are going to
get rid of edges between edges
between VI and DJ whenever VI and VJ
it's not epsilon regular get rid of the
edges between irregular parts sorry
epsilon over for regular thank you also
between parts where the edge density is
too small the edge density is less than
epsilon over two get rid of those edges
and if one of the two vertex sets has
size too small and here too small means
epsilon over 4m times the size of and so
here okay so let me use Big M for the
number of parts so that's the M that
comes out of somewhere this regularity
lemma if you like some of the vertex s
and B empty it doesn't change the proof
and n is the number of vertices in the
graph and this step you don't really
need the step if you are regular
partition is equitable okay so let's see
how many vertices how many edges have we
gotten rid of we want to show that we're
not the leading to many edges well in
the first step so some the number of
deleted
Edge's in the first step you see that
the number of edges deleted is and most
the sum of product of V I V J's when you
sum over IJ such that this pair is not
epsilon regular or epsilon for regular
I'm summing over for regular by the
definition of an epsilon regular
partition this sum here is at most
epsilon over four times N squared in the
second step I'm getting rid of
low-density pairs right by the virtue of
them being low-density I'm not removing
so many edges so at most epsilon over
two times and squared edges I'm getting
rid of in the third part you see every
time I take a very small piece every
vertex here is adjacent to a most end
vertices so the number of such things
such edges I'm getting rid of in the
last step is at most this number times
the number of parts M 10 times n so it's
at most epsilon over four times N
squared okay so here telling you how
many edges I've deleted in each step and
in total putting them together we see
that we get rid of at most epsilon and
squared edges from this graph
okay so that's the cleaning step okay so
we cleaned up the graph by getting rid
of low-density pears getting rid of
irregular pears and small vertex s now
suppose after this cleaning some
triangle still remains on to the third
step
so suppose some triangle remains okay so
what we're could this triangle set has
to be between three parts VI VJ and the
K I J and K they don't have to be
distinct alright so the argument will be
okay if some of them are the same what's
easier to draw if they're all different
so I have some triangle like that
because these edges have not yet been
deleted in the cleaning step I know that
the vertex sets are not too small the
edge densities are not too small and
they're all regular with each other so
here each pair VI VJ VK is epsilon over
for regular and edge density at least
epsilon over 2 and now we apply the
triangle counting lemma and we find that
the number of triangles with one vertex
in VI one vertex in V J one vertex in VK
is at least
this quantity here so that's a
correction factor so one over this to
epsilon and then a bunch of density so
densities are not too small so I have at
least epsilon over four and cubed
multiplied by the sizes of the vertex
sets and now I know that use the fact
that these part sizes are not too small
so just in case if I J and K happen to
be the same or two of them happen to be
the same I might over count the number
of triangles a little bit but most you
overcome by a factor six so so that's
okay so if you're worried about that for
the one over six factor in just in case
IJ K not distinct or if you like in the
cleaning step you can if you apply the
equitable version of the regularity
lemma you can also get rid of edges be
inside the parts but you know there are
many ways to do this it's not an
important step okay
now this quantity let me set it to be
Delta you see Delta is a function of
epsilon because M is a function of
Epsilon
so now looking back at the statement you
see for every epsilon there is the Delta
such that if your graph has fewer than
abdel tub and cube triangles so then
let me get rid of all the all those
edges I've gotten rid of fewer than
epsilon and squared edges and the
remaining graph should be triangle free
because if it were not triangle free
then I can find some triangle and that
would lead to a lot more triangles so
for example if you said this as Delta
over two then this was give you two
Delta and cube triangles therefore would
contradict the hypothesis and that
finishes the proof of the triangle
removal Emma right so it's saying that
thus the resulting graph is triangle
free so that's the proof of the triangle
removal lemma so let me recap we start
with a graph apply some radius
regularity lemma and clean up the
regularity partition by getting rid of
low-density pairs getting rid of
irregular pairs and getting rid of edges
touching a very small vertex set and I
claim that the resulting graph after
cleaning up should be try and go free
because if we're not triangle free and I
find some triangle then I should be able
to use that triple of vertex s combined
with a triangle counting lemma to
produce a lot more triangles and that
would violate the hypothesis of the
theorem any questions yep
great so questions where am I using
there exists a triangle if there were no
triangles then we're done right so the
purpose of the triangle the claim in a
triangle removal Emma is that you can
get rid of all triangles by removing a
most epsilon and squared edges so okay
let me try to answer your question so
why does this proof show that you still
have Delta and cube triangles so I only
set Delta at the end but of course you
can also set Delta in the beginning of
this proof so I'm saying that you do
this step you get rid of epsilon and
squared edges and now I claim after this
step so I claimed the remaining graph is
triangle free if you were not triangle
free then well have some triangle then
the triangle counting lemma would tell
me there are lots of triangles and that
would contradict the hypothesis where we
assume that this graph G has a small
number of triangles
that's right
so you're saying if you do not have any
triangles well after the cleaning step
we have gone rid of all the edges
between the bad pears and I'm claiming
that there is no configuration like this
left and this is the proof right because
if you have some configuration where you
did not delete the edges between these
three parts then you should be able to
get a lot more triangles from the
triangle counting lemma you're asking
what happens if there were lots of
triangles inside each VI VJ BK so that
is fine if you find some triangle so
this picture I J or K they do not have
to be distinct all right so the same
proof works if I J and K some of them
are equal to each other yeah
so okay you're asking why did I put a
Delta over two just because I for less
than or equal to Delta if I put strictly
less than Delta and I don't need a Delta
over two okay don't worry about it yes
okay you're asking it's your way to
generalize the triangle counting lemma
to a general graph so yes we will see
that not today but I think next time
okay more questions great so why do
people care about the triangle removal
lemma okay so it's a nice maybe somewhat
unintuitive statement but there was a
very good reason why the statement was
formulated and it's because you can use
it to prove Ross theorem so that's what
I want to explain how to connect this
graph theoretic statement to a statement
about three-term a p3 a p3 subsets of
integers and this goes back to the very
connection between graph theory and
additive combinatorics that I
highlighted in the first lecture first
let me state a corollary of the triangle
removal mmm namely that if you have an N
vertex graph G where so if so if G and
vertex and every edge is in exactly one
triangle
then the number of edges of G is little
o of N squared these are actually kind
of strange graphs every edge isn't
exactly one triangle okay
well the number of triangles in G every
edge is in exactly one triangle so the
number of triangles in G is a number of
edges divided by three the number of
edges is at most n squared so this
quantity is a most quadratic water which
in particular is little Olaf n cubed and
thus the triangle removal mo tells us
that G can be made triangle free by
removing little o of N squared edges
on the other hand since every edge is in
exactly one triangle for how many edges
do you need to remove to get rid of all
the triangles I need to remove at least
1/3 of the edges need to remove at least
1/3 of edges to make G triangle free by
putting these two claims together we see
that the number of edges of G must be
little off N squared any questions yep
great questions are there not more
elementary ways to prove this let me
make some comments about that the short
answer is yes but not really and really
the answer's no so you can ask what
about quantitative pounds because you
know what is more elementary well it's
less elementary it's kind of subjective
but quantitative pounds you know
something that is very concrete is hard
to argue so if you look at the triangle
removal mmm you can ask how is the
dependence of Delta on Epsilon
okay so what does the proof give you
where's the bottleneck bottleneck is
Oasis in the apply application of
similarities regularity lemma namely in
this M so none of the other epsilon is
really matter is this M that kills you
in terms of quantitative doubts
so in triangle removal Emma there's
proof gifts 1 over Delta also you can
take 1 over Delta being a power of twos
of height and most
polynomial in one over epsilon is you're
a different proof but the best-known
bound so due to Fox is that you can
replace this this height by a different
height that is a most essentially
logarithmic in one over epsilon it's
still a power of two's so we've changed
some really big number to another purse
lightly smaller really big number okay
so this is still an astronomical number
for any reasonable epsilon and in terms
of that corollary basically the only
known proof goes through the triangle
removal Emma currently we do not know
any other approach to this problem and
you'll see later on that well what about
you know what's the best thing that we
can hope for so it is quite possible
that there are other proofs that are yet
to be found
so that's actually no people believe
this that this is not the right proof
that maybe there's some other way to do
this and the best lower bound which
we'll see either later today or next
time shows that we cannot do better than
one over epsilon being essentially just
a little bit more than polynomial in
epsilon so epsilon raised to something
that is logarithmic in one over epsilon
so you can think of this as very not
it's a little bit bigger than polynomial
in one over epsilon but not that much
bigger than polynomial one over epsilon
so there's a very big gap in our
knowledge on what is the right
dependence between epsilon and delta in
the triangle removal lemma and that's
one of the it's a major open
from in extremal combinatorics to close
this gap other questions all right
so let's prove Ross theorem so let me
remind you that Roth's theorem which we
saw in the very first lecture says that
if you have a subset of 1 to n that is
free of 3 term arithmetic progressions
then the size of the set must be
suppling you alright so what does this
have to do with the triangle removal mmm
if you remember the first lecture maybe
the connection shouldn't be so
surprising what we will do is that we
will set up a graph such that you know
starting from some arithmetic set such
that the graph encodes some arithmetic
information in particular the three-term
a piece in your graph in the set
correspond to the triangles in the graph
ok so let's set up this graph it will be
helpful to view a knot as a subset of
the integers it will just be more
convenient to view it as a subset of a
cyclic group this more yeah I don't have
to worry about education so much when
you're working a cyclic group yeah I
take m to be 2 n plus 1 so having it odd
makes my life a bit simpler then if a is
3 AP free subset of 1 to n then I claim
that a now sitting inside the cyclic
group is also 3 AP 3 so the subset of
and what we will do is that we will set
up a certain graph so we will set up a
tripartite graph X Y Z and here XY and z
are going to be M elements whose
vertices are represented by elements of
Z mod M and then I need to tell you what
are the edges of this graph so here are
the edges by putting an edge between
vertex x and y if and only if Y minus X
is an element of a so just it's a rule
for put how to putting the edges and
this is basically a KD graph by
bipartite variant of a KD graph likewise
I put in the edge between X and Z so
actually let me put X down here and Y up
there so let me put in an edge between y
and z if I know me if y minus Z minus y
is an element of a and for the very last
pair so it's similar but slightly
different by putting that edge if and
only if Z minus X divided by 2 it's an
element of a so because we're in an odd
cyclic group I can divide by 2 okay so
this is a graph right so starting with a
set a I give you this rule for
constructing this tripartite graph and
the question now is what are the
triangles in this graph if the vertices
X Y Z is a triangle
then these three numbers by definition
because of the edges because they're all
edges in this graph these three numbers
they all lie in a but now notice that
these three numbers they form a three
term arithmetic progression because the
middle element is the average of the two
others okay but we said that a is a set
that is three AP three has no three term
arithmetic progression so so what must
be the case so a is three AP free but
you can still have three a piece using
the same element three times so all the
three term are automatic progressions
must be of that form so these three
numbers must then equal to each other in
particular you see that if you select x
and y it determines e and this equality
here is the same as saying that x y&z
they themselves form a three AP in gmod
MZ okay so this is precisely the
description of all the triangles in the
graph
okay so all the triangles in the graph G
are precisely XYZ where x y and z form a
three term arithmetic progression and in
particular every edge of G lies in
exactly one triangle you give me an edge
for example X Y I complete it to a 3 AP
XYZ and that's the triangle and that's
the unique triangle at the edge system
and likewise if you give me X Z or Y Z I
can produce for you a unique triangle
okay so we have this graph it has this
property that every edge lies in exactly
one triangle so we can apply the
corollary up there to deduce a bound on
the total number of edges
well how many edges are there on one
hand we see that because it's a Cayley
graph each of the three parts there are
three parts here each of the three parts
if I start with any vertex I have a
edges coming out of that vertex to the
next part by the construction on the
other hand by the corollary up there the
number of edges has to be little all of
em squared and because M is essentially
twice and we obtained that the size of a
is little all of em and that proves Ross
theorem
okay so question is why is every edge in
exactly one triangle so you know what
all the edges are so this is a
description of what all the edges are
and what are all the triangles XYZ is a
triangle
precisely when these three expressions
all line a but notice that these three
expressions they form a three AP because
the middle term is the average of the
two others so XYZ it's a triangle if and
only if this equation is true and this
equation is true if and only if X Y Z
form as 3 AP in Z mod M so if you just
read out this equation I have to give
you x and y right so what is Z odds so
all the triangles in XYZ are precisely
given by 3 ApS where one of the
difference is y minus x facing a ok so I
give you an edge for example X Y such
that Y minus X facing ape and I claim
there's a unique Z that completes this
edge to a triangle and it tells you what
that Z is Z has to be the element in Z
mod M that completes x and y 2 a 3 AP
namely Z is the solution to this
equation right there no other Z can work
and you can check that Z indeed works in
that all the remaining pairs are edges
so it's something you can check
any more questions alright so starting
with the set a that is three AP free we
set up this graph with a property that
every edge lies in exactly one triangle
and the one triangle basically
corresponds to the fact that you always
have this trivial three a piece
repeating the same elements three times
and then by applying this corollary of
the triangle removal lemma we deduced
that the number of edges in the graph
must be sub-quadratic so then the size
of a must be sub linear and that proves
ross theorem so we did quite a bit of
work in proving this theorem similarly
its regularity lemma counting them I'll
remove a lemma and then we set up this
graph it's not an easy theorem later in
the course we'll see a different proof
of ross theorem that goes through
fourier analysis that will look somewhat
different but it will have similar
themes so we'll also have this team
comparing structure and pseudo
randomness which comes up in the proof
in the statement and proof of summary
this graft regularity lemma or so there
it's really about understanding what is
the structure of the graph in terms of
decomposition into parts that look
pseudo-random yeah okay so question is
why do I call this graph the Kelly graph
so usually the Cayley graph refers to a
graph where I give you a group and I
give you a subset of the group and I
connect to elements if let's say their
difference lies in my subset this
basically has that form so it's not
exactly what people mean by a Cayley
graph but it has that spirit any more
questions
okay so earlier I talked about bounds
for triangle removal lemma so what about
bounds for Ross theorem what we do know
somewhat better bounds for Ross theorem
compared to you with this proof so this
is somehow it's a nice proof it's a nice
graph theoretic proof but it doesn't
give you very good bounce or it gives
you balance that they cave very poor T
as a function of n yeah so what does it
give you as a function event if you were
to replace this little ole by a function
of n according to this proof what would
you get and basically asking what is the
inverse of the function where you input
some number and it gives you a power of
Exponential's of height with that input
let's call the log star so the log star
so this is essentially n over the log
star event the log star basically is the
number of times you have to take the
logarithm to get you below one okay so
that's the log star and saying that the
log star we know that it grows to
infinity but it's never being observed
to do so it's extremely slowing slowly
growing function any more questions so I
want to okay so next time I want to show
you a construction that gives you a okay
so the next time I will show you a
construction that gives you a subset a
of n that is fairly large or so you
might ask okay so you have this upper
bound but what should the truth be and
here's more or less the state of
knowledge
[Applause]
so best bangs
try on rock theorem basically the best
bounds have the form and divided by
basically log n raised to power 1 plus
in Toma the precise bounds are deform
and over log N and then there's some
extra log log factors but let's not
worry about that the best lower bounds
so we'll see this next time so there
exists sets subsets of 1 to n such that
the size of a is at least e to the so n
times
ok so first let me say it's pretty close
to the exponent is as close to one as
you can as you wish
there exists as a such that the size of
a is n to the 1 minus the whole one and
already this fact is an indication of
the difficulty of the problem because if
you could prove Ross theorem through
some fairly elementary techniques like
using the Cauchy short a bunch of times
for instance then your experience tells
us that you probably expect some bound
that a power saving by replacing the 1
by some smaller number but that's not
the case and the fact that that's not
the case it's already indication of the
difficulty of of this upper bound of
Ross theorem even getting a little all
right so you don't expect there to be
simple proofs getting a little the
pound that we'll see next time so what's
your construction which gives you a
pound that is of this form okay so it's
maybe a little bit hard to think about
how quickly this function grows but I'll
let you think about it now how does this
okay so let's look at this corollary
here can you see a way to construct a
graph which has lots of edges such that
every edge lies in exactly one triangle
so we did this connection showing how to
use this corollary to prove roster but
you can run the same connection right so
starting from this 3 AP free a we can
use that construction to build a graph
and such that graph on n vertices with
essentially on the water off and the
times the size of a number of edges such
that every edge lies in exactly one
triangle so you run the same
construction and that's this is actually
more or less the only way that we know
how to construct such graphs that are
fairly dense so on one hand basically
what I said earlier on one hand you have
this upper bound which is given by the
proof of using similarities regularity
lemma that gives you a tower in the
upper bound on 1 over Delta and if you
use this construction here 3 AP 3 set to
construct a graph you get this lower
bound on delta which is quasi-polynomial
ok and that's that's more or less than
we know
so this is weed and it's a major open
problem to close these two gaps any more
questions so I want to give you a plan
on what's coming up ahead so today we
saw one application of similarities
regularity lemma namely to the triangle
removal lemma which has this application
to RAAS terms so we've seen our first
proof of Rosse theorem and next lecture
and the next couple lectures I want to
show you a few extensions and
applications of similarities regularity
lemma so one of the questions today was
we knew how to count triangles but what
about other graphs as you can imagine if
you can count triangles then the other
graphs should also be doable using the
same ideas and we'll do that so we'll
see how to count other graphs and we'll
give you a I'll give you a proof of the
air - stone Chimel image theorem that we
do not prove in the first part of this
course so gives you an upper bound on
the extremal number of a graph H that
depends only on the chromatic number of
H and then I also mention I will now
prove some extensions of the regularity
lemma to other settings such as - hyper
graphs and what that's useful for is
that it will allow us to deduce
generalizations of Ross theorem to
longer arithmetic progressions actual
proving Sammarinese theorem so one way
to deduce similarities theorem is to use
a hyper graph remove ulema
hyper graph extension of the graph
remove ulema the triangle removal lemma
that we saw today it would also let us
derive higher dimensional
generalizations of these theorems so
it's a very powerful tool and actually
the hyper graph removal mr has mentioned
in the very first lecture it's a very
difficult extension of the graph removal
amount and
hypergraph regularity lemma which can be
used to prove the hypergraph removal ama
is a difficult extension of the graph
regularity lemma okay so we'll see that
in the next few lectures